>>> A BILL TT WOULD BAN
ABORTION AT ALL STAG OF
PRNANCY WITH EXCEPTIONS IS ONE
STEP CLOSER TO LAW IN INDIANA.
THE VERSION THAT PASSED IN THE
SENATE PROVIDES EXCEPTIONS FOR
RAPE, INCEST AND FOR WHEN THE
LIFE OF THE PREGNANT PERSON IS
AT RISK.
AS OF NOW THE HOUSE BILL
MAINTAINED THOSE EXCEPTIONS.
A FINAL HOUSE VOTE IS EXPECTED
TO HAPPEN TODAY BEFORE THE BILL
GOES BACK TO THE SENATE TO
APPROVE OR DENY ANY CHANGES.
EARLIER I SPOKE TO INDIANAPOLIS
OB/GYN DR. CAITLIN BERNARD, SHE
IS THE DOCTOR WHO PROVIDE ADD
MEDICATION-INDUCED ABORTION TO A
10-YEAR-OLD RAPE VICTIM FROM
OHIO.
>> DOCTOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US THIS MORNING.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
BILL IN INDIANA MOVE TO THE FULL
HOUSE WHERE IT IS RELYING ON
EXCEPTIONS, INCLUDING FOR RAPE,
EXCEPTIONS FOR THE LIFE OF THE
MOTHER AS WELL.
YOU'VE TREATED MANY PATIENTS WHO
WOULD FALL INTO THESE
CATEGORIES.
WHAT DO YOU IS THE PROBLEM WITH
RELYING ON THOSE EXCEPTIONS?
>> YEAH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
YOU KNOW, MEDICINE IS NOT ABOUT
EXCEPTIONS.
I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO TELL YOU
HOW MANY PATIENTS I SEE IN VERY
UNIQUE SITUATIONS THAT CAN'T FIT
INTO THOSE EXCEPTIONS, THAT
CAN'T HAVE A LIST OF WHAT I CAN
AND CAN'T DO.
THEY CAN'T WAIT TO CHECK WITH
THEIR LAWYER, I CAN'T WAIT TO
CHECK WITH MY LAWYER.
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF PATIENTS WHEN AND WHERE THEY
NEED THAT CARE.
YOU KNOW, THE OTHER PART OF THIS
IS THIS IS GOING TO EXCLUDE 98%
OF PEOPLE WHO NEED ABORTIONS IN
INDIANA.
THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY, VERY
RESTRICTIVE AND IT'S GOING TO
HURT HOOSIER WOMEN.
>> HOW OFTEN DO YOU SEE PATIENTS
WHO ARE -- WOULD FIT UNDER THESE
UMBRELLAS FOR RAPE OR FOR INCEST
OR THEIR HEALTH OR THEIR LIFE
BEING IN DANGER?
IS THIS PRETTY REGULAR?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY DAY I GET A CONSULTATION
FOR A PATIENT WHO HAS, YOU KNOW,
A CONDITION THAT FITS INTO THOSE
EXCEPTIONS.
>> HOW DO THINGS CHANGE WHEN IT
COMES -- OR HOW DO YOU WORRY
THINGS MAY CHANGE WHEN IT COMES
TO ENFORCING THOSE EXCEPTIONS?
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
WE HONESTLY DO NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER TO YET.
IT'S VERY SCARY FOR PHYSICIANS
TO HAVE A PATIENT IN FRONT OF
YOU THAT YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED, YOU KNOW HOW TO TREAT
THEM, YOU KNOW HOW TO PREVENT
HEMORRHAGE, YOU KNOW HOW TO
PREVENT
YOU KNOW HOW TO SAVE THEIR LIVES
AND YET YOU'RE WONDERING, WELL,
WHO DO I HAVE TO CHECK WITH, WHO
IS GOING TO SECOND GUESS ME, DO
I CALL MY LAWYER, DO I CALL THE
COUNTY PROSECUTOR, YOU KNOW, IS
THIS GOING TO GO TO THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHICH WE KNOW
CAN BE INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS FOR
PHYSICIANS AS I'VE EXPERIENCED.
AND WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S MAKING THIS SUCH A
DIFFICULT PROCESS FOR PATIENTS,
RIGHT, THE IMPACT ON THE
PHYSICIANS MEANS THAT THEY CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS THE WAY
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO AND
PATIENTS WILL BE HURT.
>> IN KANSAS, WHERE WE JUST SAW
VOTERS WITH RECORD TURNOUT SAY
NO, THEY DO NOT WANT TO PAVE THE
WAY FOR THERE TO BE RESTRICTIONS
ON ABORTION, FOR THERE TO BE A
BAN ON ABORTION, TO ELIMINATE
ACCESS THERE, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION TO SEEING HOW THAT
SHAPED UP?
>> I THINK IT'S SHOWING THE
TRUTH, WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE PRIVATE
MEDICAL DECISIONS EXACTLY THAT,
PRIVATELY WITH THEIR PHYSICIAN
OR MEDICAL PROVIDER, THEIR
FAMILY, WHOM EVER IT IS THAT
ADVISES THEM.
POLITICIANS HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
SPACE IN MAKING MEDICAL
DECISIONS OR IN INSTRUCTING
PEOPLE HOW TO, YOU KNOW, MAKE
THOSE MEDICAL DECISIONS, AND
KANSAS, YOU KNOW, SHOWED THAT.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT'S ALSO
TRUE HERE IN INDIANA, AND WE
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD LISTEN TO THAT.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION IS GOING TO ANIMATE
VOTERS COMING UP?
WE HAVE MIDTERM ELECTIONS HERE,
WE HAVE SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
KANSAS.
HOW DO YOU THINK IT IS GOING TO
ANIMATE THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I THINK
PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING TO REALIZE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE SUPREME
COURT TOOK AWAY A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT, NOT JUST THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION, BUT THE RIGHT TO MAKE
PRIVATE MEDICAL DECISIONS.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS, PEOPLE
BEGIN TO REALIZE THAT THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT FOR
THEMSELVES, THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES, THEIR DAUGHTERS,
THEIR WIVES.
AND I THINK PEOPLE WILL BEGIN TO
REALIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS SOMETHING
THAT EVERY PERSON SHOULD HAVE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH PARTY.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RED/BLUE DIVISIONS.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
NEEDS FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
AND SO I HOPE THAT PEOPLE WILL
BEGIN TO REALIZE, YOU KNOW, THAT
LEGISLATURES, POLITICIANS WHO
STAND UP FOR THAT, THOSE RIGHTS,
THE RIGHT OF PRIVACY IN YOUR
MEDICAL DECISION-MAKING, IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT TO
PRESERVE AND PEOPLE THAT THEY
WILL VOTE FOR.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT PAVES THE
WAY FOR MEDICAID TO ACTUALLY PAY
FOR THE EXPENSES OF THOSE WHO DO
TRAVEL OUT OF STATE FOR ABORTION
SERVICES.
WHAT ELSE DOES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NEED TO DO, IN
YOUR OPINION?
>> I THINK, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
NOTHING THAT THEY CAN DO, YOU
KNOW IN EXECUTIVE ORDERS OR
OTHER ACTIONS, THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO BRING BACK THE RIGHT THAT THE
SUPREME COURT HAS TAKEN AWAY FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO MAKE PRIVATE
MEDICAL DECISIONS.
PHYSICIANS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR P